bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got brian
here with me thank you so much for doing
this
yeah thanks for having me on for sure
let's just jump right into it uh
m1 finance uh there's a ton of people
have heard about it what do you guys do
yeah so we are a holistic and modern
personal finance platform
we combine the best of digital investing
digital borrowing and digital banking
into one seamless application uh our
investing platform is free investing in
a custom stock and etf portfolio
our borrow platform is a low cost line
of credit
securitized against your investment
portfolio so you can borrow at two
percent
against your investment portfolio and
then we have a high yield uh checking
account so a checking account that
provides you
one percent interest on your checking
account as well as one percent cash back
through an m1 issued debit card
and everything works together in a very
seamless intuitive fashion so you can
set up automated rules so every dollar
is
intelligently allocated to your
personalized plan
many people who are listening to this
have probably heard of super apps
especially coming out of the east
and you guys have described m1 as kind
of a finance super app uh
talk a little bit about the just
philosophical
kind of approach to building this you
need some of the products you already
have but
why think of it as a super app and kind
of how does that drive the product
development or the product suite that
you create
yeah so i think you know if you look at
how people manage their money now
they'll probably have a finance folder
on their phone and it's
i don't know 15 20 different
applications and you're trying to like
do
every single money movement manually you
have to do the trades you have to wait
for things to settle
and it's just become a little bit of a
mess and there's a benefit to having
all your money in one place that you
know i think from the ideal perspective
the user goes to
a application a platform and they say i
use this to manage my money i use it to
manage my finances and the notion of
a checking account a brokerage account
that's very like legal in nature and it
shouldn't really matter to the
end consumer it's just you know i have
to manage my individual finances
i think historically the the banks have
done that they just did
a pretty mediocre job of it you know
they would have a checking account
they'd have an auto loan they'd have a
brokerage account
but they felt like pretty distinct
products just under the same brand
umbrella
m1 really tries to think of it as how
can you manage your money holistically
how can you view
your assets and your liabilities or your
investments in your borrowing how can
you manage your cash flow how do you
spend and receive money
and how does each one of those enhance
one another and so the perfect example
of that is we have a free investing
platform so you can invest in exactly
what you want to invest in
and because of that we can offer you
cheaper and lower cost borrowing rates
than you can get anywhere else
so it's not something that you can put
together with sort of point solutions
out there and put it together in your
finance folder it's only when you bring
everything under the same
platform that you're able to have these
synergistic effects in managing your
money
it's it's basically you get an
efficiency of scale to some degree right
efficiency of scale and it's you know if
i'm trying to loan you money
and i don't have your assets i'm looking
at your credit score i'm looking at your
income i'm trying to verify that
versus a if i know you have you know x
amount of dollars
invested with me and i have the you know
ability to see into that at any given
basis i just have more information on
you
and so it's a efficiency of scale it's a
you know uh
like more information spectrum and so
the ability to
and it's a it's a moving money
internally on the m1 platform is
instantaneous
moving it to chase bank takes a day you
know moving it to wells fargo it takes a
day moving into schwab you know it
so there's just like synergistic effects
to managing everything cohesively rather
than putting together a bunch of
solutions out there
so this idea of a finance super app has
been very well received by the market
i literally had to write this down to
make sure that i got it all right
you did a 33 million dollar series b in
june of 2020 45 million dollar series c
in october of 2020 and then you just did
a 75 million dollar series d
in march of this year why is it growing
so fast and where's that growth coming
from
yeah uh it's fun hearing those numbers
but
so i think it's you know we were talking
about like the
the banks out there haven't done that
great of a job and it's something that
your finances are so incredibly
important it's something that every
single person
has to manage their money how you manage
it has like a drastic
effect on the quality of like your life
what you're able to do what you're able
to afford
and the tools are just pretty bad and so
you know it's something that when i was
started m1 we started in mid-2015
i looked at it in every consumer
application outside of finance
had been improved in spades you know it
was sort of unrecognizable to what you
could do 10 15 years ago
and the brokerage platforms the banking
platforms have not changed
at all and so i think it's there is now
a lot of innovation there's a lot of
uh you know consumerization going into
the finance space much like
the rest of the world and it's bringing
to par what people should expect with
their money
and it's just there's a lot of people
out there with lots of money to manage
and they're just looking for the best
tool
the nice thing is you know m1 has ridden
a a wave
of you know what we're doing as well as
some of the other fintech innovators as
sort of pushing the the boundaries of
what's possible with money management
yeah so obviously as you continue to
improve kind of the technology product
and then incorporate that philosophical
approach it's like a finance super app
you're really targeting retail investors
here right or kind of retail
uh asset owners and so as you do that
uh it happens to be coinciding with this
like rise of the retail trader
uh so there's all this talk whether it's
gamestop dogecoin or name your other
asset
uh where folks are uh essentially just
day trading right or kind of short term
investing
uh you seem to be much more geared
towards long-term investing and less
about the day trading type
kind of approach talk a little bit just
about the difference between those two
um and why focus on the long-term
investing rather than that short-term
investing that everyone else seems to be
profiting off of right now
yep for sure so you know m1 is
definitely oriented towards
long-term wealth building and wealth
management so we we think of things you
know
you're saving for your retirement your
kids education
your second vacation home it's you know
these very like substantive things where
you're trying to save bulk of money
rather than you know make money on
thursday and so
uh i think there you can be successful
in both and you know
the traders have done incredibly well uh
you know year to date or the last 12
months or whatever it may be
um i think there there are two different
mentalities trading you're trying to
play off the price movements you know
it's like
the the market says something is worth x
on you know
tuesday at 10 a.m and then it's x plus
five percent at tuesday at
2 p.m that happens i think
the we take a mentality that that's
actually relatively rough to predict
they're going to be random fluctuations
and there is a little bit of uh you know
flip of the coin aspect of whether
you're going to be right and wrong it's
exhilarating it's fun but it's probably
not the best strategy
and you get this you know aspect of it's
incredibly tax and efficient
even if you make money one time you know
you have to continually do it over and
over again
versus long-term investing is buying and
buying ownership stakes and the
ownership stakes
of you know the companies the asset
class they have an intrinsic value and
what you're trying to do is benefit by
the intrinsic value increasing over long
periods of time
and so if you're buying into a company i
actually think it's easier to say this
company is going to
produce more it's going to you know
improve margins it's going to grow
revenue
and be a more valuable company in five
ten years than it's
saying you know this price movement is
going to move on you know
in the next three days and i'm going to
play earnings and you know try to guess
better than the street
and so it's really just a different
mentality of you know
playing price movements versus buying
ownership stakes and benefiting by the
ownership stake and m1 has just been
always oriented and geared towards that
and so
we we say that for investing you're
actually making relatively infrequent
decisions
it's what do where do i want my money to
be held at any given time
and you're trying to hold it for you
know months years decades
and so what actually becomes tough is
you have incremental money with your
paycheck every two weeks and how do you
put that to work and so
m1 is much more geared about you tell
the platform here's how i want my money
managed
and then anytime you have incremental
dollars it just is automated according
to your custom plan and so it's the sort
of
routine administrative nature that is
automated rather than the you know
short-term fun
trading aspect of things that uh that
has been been on cnbc a lot lately
well it almost feels like in some way
you're really building technology to
help
humans uh avoid the pitfalls of being
human rights all the emotional decision
making all the short-term
kind of optimizations and really what it
gets at is this idea of discipline
around being an investor right and kind
of sticking to
a long-term thesis or a long-term view
talk a little bit about maybe some
things that you guys have done
in the product itself uh to adhere to
that
idea of discipline and in the long-term
nature there's specific things that
maybe
you do that others in the market don't
do that you think kind of pushes people
to to be more long-term oriented
yeah so um 100 agree with that we we
talk a lot about financial well-being
and you know
doing beneficial habits and automating
those habits so that you don't have to
consistently remake the decision
and so it's you know the exact same as
working out or eating well it's
it's whether you do that like somewhat
well over long periods of time versus
you know you hit the gym
really hard you know next week and so
for for m1
you you actually can't trade on the
platform so buying and selling intraday
is just something that
isn't supported and so you know if you
do want to make the trade there are
better platforms out there we're not
that good at it
um m1 is all about a portfolio
allocation so you're deciding hey this
is how i want my portfolio allocated as
a whole
then what we're doing is anytime money
is distributed into that and you can set
up recurring deposits so you know 500
with your paycheck every two weeks we
survey how your portfolio has done
relative to your allocation and we
intelligently direct the money and
the the way that we do it is basically
enforcing a buy low sell high so
you know if you want something to be 10
of your portfolio and it's only seven
we're going to buy more of it we're
going to dynamically rebalance your
portfolio
and we're going to say you know we're
going to with that sort of control
risk tolerance we're going to
systematically buy low and sell high
and then we have a lot of other products
on the platform you know we have ira
accounts and free ira accounts so you
know
thinking systematically about how do i
like
invest and save for in a tax advantage
way for long periods of time
we have our borrow product which lets
you
tap into the liquidity of your portfolio
at incredibly low interest rates which
does a lot of things it allows you to
invest more so you don't have to sort of
like sit on the sidelines with this
cash build up sort of having a rainy day
fund and so you can always feel
comfortable putting it to work having it
work for you
and you still have access to the
liquidity it is also like a huge tool
for
um minimizing taxes so you never have to
you know if you want to tap into the
liquidity of your portfolio you don't
have to
sell incur taxable events and so it's
it's sort of the culmination of all
those things that just
automate the beneficial behaviors of
personal financial management and
do it over long periods of time yeah
what happens to the incumbents here like
all these legacy
uh banks all of this legacy
infrastructure
brokerage accounts etc do they just get
completely wiped out
by kind of fintechs in general and this
idea of a finance super app and and kind
of what you guys are doing
or is there a coexistence do they have
to evolve like just walk me through how
you think that plays out
i think it's a coexistence and i
actually think it's somewhat
generational and so
m1 actually looks you know and thinks
incredibly highly of charles schwab and
vanguard
and we talk about it as m1 wants to
create the 2020 version of those
companies they were created in the 1970s
and if you look at vanguard it was a
better product better pricing than the
mutual funds
and charles schwab was a better product
better pricing than the wirehouse
brokerages
and so over incredibly long periods of
time they compounded at incredibly high
rates and now they're you know 100
billion dollar behemous
vanguard custodies i don't know 6
trillion bucks or whatever it may be
and you know really just reinforce
better product better pricing
and i think it's it's not like morgan
sandler merrill lynch
i guess merrill lynch went away but
morgan's you know they're in bank of
america now but you know it's not like
morgan stanley's
away it's just you know it has a
demographic it
like it's almost people who are you know
60 plus are comfortable
overpaying for their financial services
you know people who are 40 to 60 are
currently on the the schwabs of the
world they're comfortable overpaying
and it's something that these new
generations of platforms whether it's
you know ourselves robin hood
the the robos the the bitcoin platforms
out there are going to get a
disproportionate share of this new
generation
and i think they're going to hold on to
them and be that generational player for
10 20 years and at that point they're
gonna hold the mass affluent audience
and then you're gonna have your new
fintech players you know coming in and
getting the
uh new 20 and 30 year olds to sign up
for the platform so i think it's
it's more generational i do think the
banks
you know the nice thing is they have
like brand name and profits and you know
all that kind of stuff having a like
legacy code base all the retail branches
all that
that would be a massive hindrance and i
think it's you know
very difficult to sort of compete with
that as like an anchor dragging along
whereas the the world as a whole not
just financial services
is digitizing everything and having your
expertise be in that realm just
massively benefits you versus the
these old incumbent players yeah what's
so fascinating to me
is um i think this is still true uh when
atms first came out
uh everyone yelled and screamed and said
oh my god they're going to kill the bank
branches right bank tellers they're
going to be no longer needed and so
you're going to put all the bank tellers
out of business
uh but what ended up happening is
there's now more bank tellers than ever
before
right why well because the atms actually
increased the usage of the banking
system which therefore
drove more people in so i always think a
lot about like uh yeah sure
theoretically
uh the world should work where better
technology or new companies come and
disrupt the incumbents but actually
what is more likely is the user base
that you guys are on boarding
were folks who probably weren't doing
that much investing previously right
it's a younger generation and so you're
actually bringing more and more people
into
kind of these investing platforms which
is a net positive and kind of grows the
overall pie
um and so is that what you're seeing in
the actual data is this mostly
young people um especially over the last
year or so with the pandemic and kind of
macro environment
or is it pretty spread out across
demographics and geographies and
kind of all these things that people are
talking about i actually think it's
probably more spread out than people
anticipate especially with the m1 user
base i do think in a lot of the other
fintechs it is introducing a
net new you know investor to to invest
for the first time and
you know when things go up into the
right it's uh it's exciting it's
exhilarating and so people are having a
lot of fun with it
um for for m1 i think we gear a little
bit more to
a slightly more affluent crowd than the
the
uh some of the other fintechs and as a
result you know just affluence is
almost like directly proportional to age
and so we're a little bit older then
than that and so you know our average
account balance is in the tens of
thousands we have
you know four billion dollars on the
platform that has 5xed over the last
year
in it people bringing over 50 000
accounts quarter million dollar accounts
low single digit million dollar accounts
from the
incumbent players which is really booing
the aum and so it
for for m1 our growth is more driven by
a
what we call like mass affluent five six
low seven figures of investable assets
really looking for a better tool i think
they're they're a little frustrated that
the schwabs of the world the fidelities
of the world the ameritrades e traits
they haven't innovated in you know 20
years and the only change that they made
was going free due to
fintech pressures pushing them that way
and so you know i think it's it's
the innovation and the better product
experience is led by the
new entrances into the space the the
fintech peers it it depends whether
people are
sort of more comfortable you know having
a like truthfully
worse user experience but just having
the the credibility of a
established brand name that has been
there for you know decades and decades
yeah you've talked a couple of times
about various products or kind of this
idea of free
what's your business model how do you
make money and then how do you think
about that kind of aligning interest
with the user
yeah so we have uh three main products
and one invest m1 borrow and one spend
we also have an annual
paid subscription so all those are you
know free by default but we have a paid
subscription
that's sort of like an amazon prime it's
if you want the best of m one you you
can pay in to get that so that's the
easiest to understand
uh that being said we make money on all
three of our products so
m1 invest we can uh monetize the cash
that people hold on the platform
we actually do a lot of securities
lending so there's a big marketplace to
borrow securities out there we can lend
the securities out much like a bank
takes in deposits lends out deposits we
can take in securities fund out
securities
and then we do get that boogie man a
payment for order flow which i you know
we can go into as much depth as you want
it's not as bad as people think
um we m1 borrow we charge a rate and our
cost of capital is less than that so
we're earning a spread
and then on the spend side of the world
it's much like a bank so we make money
on the deposit as well as any time
someone swipes the card of interchange
and so you you have really i mean m1
makes money on the assets held on the
platform the borrowings through the
platform and the transactions and it's
really just if we become someone's
primary financial institution it's a
very
like vibrant and healthy uh business in
terms of you know being free and sort of
aligning with the the interests of our
consumer
um i think you know financial services
has been like
a lot of aspects of it have been free
for a long time i mean you know the
the like very few people pay for a
checking account and
they're taking in the the cash and the
bank like monetizes the cash balances
but they provide you a service to sort
of have that like double-sided
marketplace
a credit card you know there might be an
annual fee but oftentimes they pay you
to use it you know you
you swipe and they pay you one one and a
half percent and i think it's really
just the the dynamics of how the money
is exchanged and where
money can flow i do think the not having
an explicit charge
for the the services is does align
interest and i think
those revenue streams sort of exist
whether you charge or not and i think
it's just you know m1 and the companies
like it are saying we can survive solely
on that we don't have to charge in
addition to these back-end revenue
streams
yeah talk a little bit about the payment
for order folks i think people don't
understand actually how that works and
then
uh why uh platforms choose to do it and
kind of what the benefits are but i
think they've heard a lot about the
downsides but maybe just explain real
quickly how that works and then what the
benefits are
yeah so um we are a brokerage so that's
what we're regulating that allows us to
buy and sell
stocks and ets for customers when we go
and buy and sell stocks and ets we have
the option to send it to
an open exchange so the new york stock
exchange nasdaq a few others
or there are execution venues they're
called wholesalers and that's the
citadels the virtues the two sigmas of
the world
in any one of those cases there's going
to be a different
uh amount of what you pay versus like
sell a security for
and the difference between that is the
spread and on the open exchange there is
a
you know spread it may be a penny it may
be five pennies and then there are also
exchange
fees and so m1 we have the ability to
send it to nizee
and you know pay the like spread
equivalent and the exchange fees
what the wholesalers do is they actually
compete and say we will offer you
better pricing than what you can get on
the open exchange so we will
like execute between the spread we will
give you better prices for buys better
prices for sales
and we will make up for it in volume
that's their whole proposition and so
they're basically competing on
efficiency and compressing the spreads
and giving better pricing to the people
who are executing
and to make up for it in volume they'll
actually pay brokerages to send it there
that
you know they're making a fraction and
they say hey we want as much volume as
possible we'll send it there
and so i do think it's an advantageous
relationship where the customer the end
retail customer
does get better pricing if we were to
send it to the open exchange you would
get worse pricing and so
you know it's something that we can
advantage both the
individual retail consumer by giving
them better execution pricing
and we also get paid for it and so that
covers the cost of developing the
product developing the platform you know
executing these trades on the customer's
behalf and so i actually do think it's a
um it's a unique like business model i
actually think works incredibly well
there are downsides associated with it i
think you know it's not all not positive
the the worry is if you have all of this
operating in sort of this like opaque
you know uh
like off the open exchanges you won't
have as much
pricing transparency um i buy the
argument i don't think we're there yet
um from just like how much
gets executed on each but those would be
the arguments for both i actually think
it's
it's better pricing and you know the
brokerage gets paid for it
the downside would be there'd be less
pricing transparency if it took over
the vast majority of the market got it
that all makes sense what's next for you
guys
so i mean you know we we talk about
ourselves as the the finance super app
and so
we really do want to be anything and
everything that people can do to manage
their money
so we have the invest borrow spend we
think those are like pillars of
m1 and that will be our pillars moving
forward but we'll move
more into different types of lending so
we'll you know
we we have it against your liquid assets
we'll be able to you know
lend against your hard assets over your
home whether that's a mortgage or heloc
unsecured and really just say hey this
is what is available to you we're
underwriting you as a person we're going
to give you the best rates most flexible
terms that you can borrow at will
on the spending side we're coming out
with a credit card and we're doing very
unique things on the credit card where
you get benefits based on what's in your
investment portfolio you can also pay
off your credit card with that
incredibly low line of credit and so
you know you're never defaulted into you
know 22 credit card debt it's
it's two percent you know so it it's
better um and so you know we're we're
just going to enhance sort of every
pillar of m1
you know invest borrow spend and just go
deeper in each and really focus on the
automation and the synergies between all
of them
yeah it's awesome what's the number one
thing you've learned you've gone
incredibly fast you've had a lot of
success but you as a founder what's the
number one lesson you've learned
uh since you started the company in 2015
that uh you think other founders could
benefit from knowing
ah i mean there's like a million lessons
inside
uh i i do think it's it's you you start
with a
idea in that it matters that being said
it more matters how you execute against
that and how you execute that is the the
people that you bring on to
help you along the way so you know
having a
okay idea or a good idea is helpful to
start with but it doesn't matter unless
you bring
incredible people along the way that you
know the the company is
hundreds of thousands or millions of
decisions made over the past five years
and you need really strong capable
people to do that and so
finding like people that believe in the
mission
you know have a similar mindset work
hard have a you know just
raw horsepower associated with them i
think that's you know 95 plus percent of
the
the determinant of success i think that
you're probably more right than wrong on
that one uh ask the same three questions
to everyone uh before we wrap up and
you'll get to ask me one
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
um most important book um stephen pinker
how the mind works
i i like geek out on
economics and you know that side of
things and then you know like the
behavioral economics
type thing has sort of like taken over
the econ field and i think just like a
intrinsic fundamental understanding of
how humans and their biology
dictate thought and you know creativity
and why you make decisions
i it just you know it it opens your eyes
and it sort of informs you know how how
the world works generally and so i've
absolutely loved that book yeah that's a
great answer
uh second question comes from our
friends over at eight sleep uh they've
got this thermo
uh kind of regulated bed where i used to
sleep you know five six hours now i
sleep on this really cold mattress uh
and sleep like a baby seven eight nine
hours
uh and it completely changed the way
that i thought about sleep what's your
sleep
been like over the years uh and kind of
what is it today
um so i recently purchased that they are
having shipping delays because the
product is
so popular in the likes so you know if
you have an in for them to ship it
quicker it is getting delivered to me
shortly
i so my
mom and dad were like they could survive
on four or five hours of sleep and i
felt like it was a superpower
i need like an eight and a half nine
hours i am i get grumpy i get
you know i am not a good uh sleeper
generally and so i
sleep more than i would like i am pretty
like dogmatic and religious about
getting good sleep because it i i do buy
into that like
how my day goes is pretty well
determined by how i slept
the night before i i when we get off
this i'm gonna introduce you to
the ceo i'm gonna tell him rush deliver
immediately
to uh uh the third question
uh a little bit more fun aliens are you
a believer or a non-believer
ah they gotta exist the universe is too
big it's it's sort of just like a random
you know i i know like i i buy into the
fermi paradox of like where are they if
they're they're so advanced but
it seems more unlikely than not that
they uh
they're not out there i i completely
agree i
i understand why people think that uh uh
we should have seen them where are they
whatever
listen if you think that we know
everything that we're supposed to know
uh you are uh much more optimistic about
our knowledge base
than uh than i am right for sure you get
into that you know the whole like speed
of light thing and you're
i mean even humans just haven't had like
radio waves going out for that far so
you know
we we haven't explored much of the the
universe so it's uh
the the youtube videos that i watch make
the university very very large and so i
think it's reasonable that they're
some far out there i tend to think
you're right
uh what one question you have for me to
uh to finish up i would love for
you to i know you're the the bitcoin
guys tell me on why we should
add bitcoin to the m1 platform
listen i always tell people like open
systems
are going to win over closed systems and
the legacy financial system
is a closed system right and what i mean
by that is
uh when you have a open system like
bitcoin anyone in the world with an
internet connection can simply plug into
it
and now get all of the economic benefits
of a store value medium of exchange
uh and also kind of this payment
application and so
for you guys specifically if i said to
you hey i know a payment app
that payment app is growing 200
year-over-year compounded for a decade
plus
uh and it has the ability to process and
will this year
process over five trillion dollars of
on-chain transaction volume
right so it's bigger than apple pay
venmo or paypal what if i told you that
you could strike a partnership
with the application tomorrow and you
didn't have to do any of the legalese
you'd have to do anything all you had to
do was put a little technology and plug
into it
most people i think say hey that's
pretty interesting right how could we
benefit from it how could we on board
people etc
and so i think that's really the way
that uh i think about it for kind of
legacy fintech right and legacy being
literally uh there's legacy traditional
finance then there's like legacy fintech
and now there's just like crypto stuff
um it's just simply that you've got this
open network of
uh kind of a payment system uh that has
incredible volume
has literally hundred plus million users
uh
and what it affords an opportunity for
is for you simply just to plug into it
right now that doesn't mean that all the
users are going to go use it right
there's plenty of fintech companies who
said hey you can now buy and sell
bitcoin or you can hold bitcoin here
whatever um and so it's not kind of all
just positive you got to look at the
regulatory framework you had to look at
hey does our user base want this what
are they going to do with it
does our user base if they're not going
to trade it would they hold it for a
long period of time does it align with
our mission and ethos
all of that kind of goes into the
decision making but i think it's just
more of one of these things where
uh folks look at the speculative nature
of it right just the the day trading and
kind of all the things that we talked
about that you guys don't do
that kind of gets all the headlines but
if you actually look at the underlying
fundamentals of it as a financial asset
and the growth and uh adoption uh it's
pretty damn compelling so i think that's
pretty much the argument
yeah no it's a good argument like i'm
able to do like a quick
follow-up yeah of course how much of it
do you think is like
driven by it being a tech improvement
and you know sort of like the blockchain
technology versus the regulatory stuff
because you know
like i i don't actually have that strong
position on it but i i question like
are some of those things possible with
current technologies and it's just
they're not allowed
in the regulatory framework that we have
or is sort of crypto and blockchain sort
of a net new thing that
only because it's what it is allows for
that openness and sort of all the the
attributes that you mentioned
yeah so let's talk about bitcoin
specifically maybe compared to like the
legacy world right so like a simple
thing would be if the stock market went
24 7 365
that would be then the kind of a feature
parity with the bitcoin market right
trace 24 7 365. so that to me feels like
that's much more of
a kind of regulatory and what i'll just
call like business decision making
there's no reason why the stock market
doesn't trade 24 7 365
other than they historically have not
done that and therefore they're not
going to do it you know anytime soon
uh but there are some very very
significant technical advantages that
can't be replicated by the legacy world
right so when you think of kind of this
decentralized
open system uh the last decentralized
open system that we had was the internet
and so people did go and build kind of
uh competition to that
open system right they built intranets
or uh even companies like aol etc
uh but what you ultimately find is like
again open systems beat the closed
systems and so
what i think you're starting to see is
uh you i and
most people that we probably know have a
very western-centric view of the world
but it's actually really really hard for
people outside the united states to
get bank accounts and brokerage accounts
participate in the u.s market and kind
of do all this stuff
now with this uh idea of these kind of
crypto markets what you do is you just
need an internet connection
and you can simply go on you can log in
it's probably very similar like logging
into
m1 right it's just a much better
experience than like charles schwab
sending you a bunch of papers to sign up
or whatever
and so i think when you start to
drastically reduce friction and open the
accessibility and then you've got this
market that again you know trades 24 7
365
and the assets themselves have very
specific um
kind of criteria to it it just is a
free market competition between the
legacy system and this new system
uh and actually the legacy system has a
massive advantage right they've got
brand names they've got a lot of capital
in it they've got a regulatory regime
that is more favorable to it all that
kind of stuff
but still people are moving to this new
system and some of it's generational
like you talked about earlier right
where you just got a lot of young people
who they like this their digital native
and they're going
uh but also i think what you're getting
is you're getting some decision making
where people are looking at the macro
environment that's pushing people to
this new system right they're saying hey
all the money printing and stuff
it doesn't really make sense to me uh
and then ultimately like what you're
going to get
i don't know 30 years from now it's just
you're going to get a bunch of people
that their first interaction with the
financial system was not the legacy
system it was with the digital system
right or kind of this new system
and so i don't think it's a binary like
hey the legacy system dies and the new
one wins i think it's actually
coexistence and some of the legacy
players you know they adapt they
they'll thrive in this new world and
some will be hurt by it um but i think a
lot of actually the way that you look at
m1 versus like the traditional financial
platforms is similar to how i look at
like
crypto and uh fintech and so
yeah the world's not binary it's not
black and white it is very gray and so i
think that uh
you know it's a thing where those who
kind of uh empower their users to do it
earlier probably benefit a little bit
more but
even if you wait a year and do it later
like your users will still get some
benefit out of it it's just kind of you
know how much
uh kind of asymmetry is there it all
depends on what uh what a company's
goals and objectives are
yep makes sense good argument i've done
it once or twice
yeah i'm sure i've got a little bit
you've had the
probing and the the rebuttals that are
you know from people better informed
than i am so
no uh where can we send people to learn
more about m1
and uh learn more about you and find you
on the internet if they want to follow
up or follow along with what you're
doing
yeah so i mean m1 we have web and mobile
app so m1finance.com or we're in the
play store
uh or uh app store on you know ios or
android
uh we have media profiles on sort of all
the major social
media sites and so we have a big
subreddit community you know tens of
thousands of people talking about the
the good bad and the ugly about m1 so
there's a lot of places to find us
online awesome well listen thank you so
much for doing this i really appreciate
it i'm fascinated with what you guys are
building
uh cheering for you guys and please
we'll have this again in the future
yeah absolutely no really a lot of fun
and thanks for having me on